ela é muito grandes obras não só os 21
gols
[Música]
o lado pessoal e quem fala é o dark
sejam muito bem vindos mas não brilham e
o strategic oil time potiguar não só se
lembram eu iria comprar uma aranha e
algumas oferecem do flamengo daquela
senhora igreja incrédula e imaginei que
é bom é maranhão tecla ou esta ter ampla
é tanto a maior do mundo é muito grande
só tem 30 sentindo só vamos mostrar como
é que está a usar o meu tá muito linda é
tipo um funcionário bem sombrio tipo
cemitério está muito lindo mesmo e vamos
mostrar também aranha o promotor ela já
tá aqui no meu quarto está mesmo aqui ao
meu lado mas primeiro só vocês têm que
deixar aqui muito liquidez time e quando
você só vocês acharem muito vai que você
vê que vocês vão gostar daqui deste
conteúdo e da minha aranha e eu vou
continuar a fazer mais coisas demonstrar
como alimento em aranha que é muito
interessante porque esta tarefa é uma
tranquila goiás a maior do mundo
portanto ela como sapos como passo como
errado meu eu não tô brincar e
selecionamos aqui no canal pessoal
inscreva se aqui no canal é que vai ter
muito contente novo é que deve se
mostrar tranqüilo vou falar um pouco
sobre ela só para vocês perceberem o que
eu tenho aqui no quarto que eu escolhi
para mim é um animal de estimação é uma
tarântula golias é só talento é melhor
do mundo não é maior a equipa segunda
ela tem 30 centímetros quando adulta meu
30 centímetros equipa palma da vossa mão
tona meu é muito grande
imaginei que isto é uma aranha e elas
foram 25 anos portanto vou tê lo por
muito tempo essa tarefa wang leve entrar
mazoni porque ela a floresta chegando lá
mas porque estou com pressa do maranhão
por que não pratiquem cão um gato
sei lá um pouco porque eu gosto disso
ela tem dois dentes muito afiados ou
dentro dela tem um sentido e minha
paciência oriental e dentro da caixa de
bioshock ela pode ser muito perigosa
porque ela tem o seu próprio veneno ela
quando faz uma infecção grande e
não é só isso ela tem urticária e tem
veneno ea causa dela que ela tem umas
gotinhas assim atrás resposta dessas
cozinhas quando tocam na outra ela
lançou um pouco sozinho e após entrar em
contacto com os vossos jogos vocês ficam
tribunal rejeitou ontem lá
ai meu deus aí voltei com pode ter ampla
ae
caixas atm alimento de ter ampla que são
baratos de grill como vocês já viram ela
pode ser um animal perigoso mas também
da produção explicar que ela consegue
andar em cima de mim a vontade
simplesmente ela sentir ameaçada ela vai
morder e isso um dia e vento o homem vai
acontecer né mas ela pode andar à
vontade em cima de mim é que eu tenho
aqui por acaso é muito má é muito amiga
mesmo portanto era boa e tranqüila que
eu tenho aqui fmi é importante eu posso
seduzi la com um charme como charme ela
no more uma lei muito rock alimentação
para a argentina que são baratos muito
grande barato é normal tipo doméstica é
bem pequena e muitos gritos dela com
muito frio mas isso é só em sexo anal
inset de paula também com muita outra
coisa kato árvores pequenas já é passado
porque em sapos cobras lagartos
ela contudo o que for mais pequeno do
que ela é um pouco maior que é o twitter
ampla como cobra como assim o inter atua
com cobre e por estas razões todas eu
comprei essa tranqüila porque eu achei
muito interessante aliás eu não comprei
foi o tuga que ofereceu uma loja em
portugal os animais quiserem algum
animal passei lá pessoal porto é o
senhor muito simpático que tem muitos
animais mesmo plano lógico eu passei lá
na loja deus pessoal quando fui visitar
a minha esperança e faz uns o que
aconteceu o pessoal aqui está a minha
talento lá ela vai morrer e olha isso é
muito grande então fuja olha isso vai
correr mal eu também acho que vai correr
mal não é muito grande é muito grandes
obras não só os dentes dela só vou
cansar esta luva acha que as cenas não é
também acho que não
eu acho que eu acho que dentro dela
passa a lua na única não vou tocar nisso
né não
primeiro estranha se dentro rico é que
joga na missa e depois nasce depois de
sentar nas costas
assim boa ghanem só você não sabe vocês
viram sabe que elas atuam perante o
assalto não é não é coisa normal tanto
eu escolhi não esta vai ser a minha
tarefa é porque ela conseguiu andar em
cima dele e não mordeu então
esse que eu quero né pode ser que ela
também é em cima de mim não muda é nossa
igual sempre acontecer uma vez por duas
vezes não aconteceu portanto eu confiei
e depois disto tudo no fim do dia o
pessoal da tortuga vai ficar pra montar
um claro que ficou muito bom ficou
pronto a lutar mesmo que ele foi mesmo
sombrio no cemitério e vamos mostrar
isso ao este é o meu salário
[Música]
não podem ver pessoal numa carta que
cumpriu tal mesmo tá muito bom com um
tapa em sombrio banho cemitério é que
tem uma campa concluir
aqui tem mais uma cavaleira bié que eu
mais gosto é uma caveira do que com é eu
consegui tirá lo da equipe que era
transportada numa árvore morta tá muito
logo sério ele o fundo tenha partido
dela bagwell não beba com todos juntos
animais rock pela bp uma gelatina estas
rotina aqui basicamente o amor das
rotinas se o gago que tem lá dentro e
depois eu tenho que voltar a encher com
água e esgoto china vai absorver a água
e ela volta a viver é assim é muito
interessante mesmo faltou arriscar muito
e minha vida porque o cara está
completamente aberto que ela está ali
dentro dormir eu acho que está a dormir
é por supostamente ter ampla é uma
tarântula noturna ou seja ela de dia
dorme à noite quando caça quando brinca
e só passaram pela trip com muita árvore
veio ter que estar brigando mas não só
começaram por esse que tá morta já está
aqui há muito tempo e possui que esta
foi a gente também para lembrar um pouco
a amazônia época tranquila tem se sentir
em casa e outra coisa muito louca é que
esta carreira aqui brilha no escuro essa
caverna e este com ele se ela não se
conseguem ver mas esta câmera está
abrigado em louco é que na hora eu tenho
um tributo está que mede a temperatura
do terrário emenda um milagre porque eu
tenho uma equipe só porque eu tenho que
simular o habitada minha tanya sabita é
um habitar um mito e quente esse momento
mais tropical é porque é o que elas
gostam é quente e húmida crime em dias
de calor como é que deixa a terra úmida
mas como é que botar quente e úmido ao
mesmo tempo é só puxar um pouco tarde
com água e fica o medo vocês não ser
aprender a cuidar fran e que por baixo
não é normal isso que acho que é fibra
de coco o que está em melhor ou mirado
ea água portanto está sempre me ir para
este problema está muito louco meu aqui
excluídos enterrados porque já morreram
é tem um saque também bem louco e como
temos muito perto alumínio também já fiz
aqui uma decoração do aluno e eu sou o
cara que este esqueleto e as questões
com aranhas belo e ela como uma aranha
que gosta muito de seguir as coisas vêm
trocar tudo aqui tem textura portanto
ela pode inspirar pode subir lá atrás
até a cabeça do quintão e pois tem os
prognósticos não se conseguem mesmo mas
tem aqui um braço não exclui disputado
na pedra anderson externo e agora só
vamos mostrar onde queria ter ampla dora
e qual é o city fury tela geralmente
costuma andar ali quando está noite o
pedagogo entender-se alimento mas
normalmente quando estava no dia que o
ela dorme é lina que o tronco eu vou
tentar mostrar que eu vou chegar aqui o
cara com ela não fugir toalha vamos
tentar mostrar ela está ali dentro de um
tronco támbém no buraco lior a divulgar
que o fla só vocês conseguem ver ela
está mesmo em baixo uma lei pode parecer
pequeno mas ela já é bem grande ela tem
20 centímetros e ela só tem um ano um
ano de vida e eu saí pessoal eu sei que
vocês querem ver é vocês querem que o pt
ter ampla mexe eu não vou fazer isso
porque o contrário é novo então eu vou
deixá lo descansar vou deixar a
ambientar seu terrário só da tortura
quando vê que a montar o time búlgaro
nela e ela parece bastante calma são
muito rápidas porque elas são ótimas
caçadoras de instrumentação da área para
que ela não muda pro céu meu amor de
cristo são autênticos gigantes
beneficiadas ela mora toda a volta das
patinhas e do corpo delas é causa alguma
ficar alguma comichão eu particularmente
depois do carro melhorando o tempo
passar todo em álcool porque não fico
com muita comichão e esses transtornos
não só essas péssimas
esta empresa em particular têm uma
defesa que quando se sente ameaçada ela
perde duas patas das farc na zona do
domínio do meio campo e isso quando
ingerido em nível de energia causando
muita tosse muito ficar em muita
comichão e basic edição fez aquela taipé
é para afastar o seu potencial
empreendedor mas é sempre bom deixá lo
descansar um pouco mais tarde comecei a
pegar nela tentar eu não posso pegar
nela mas possa alimentar hoje ao jn uma
caixa que foi outro agora é só abrir
aqui o usuário e vamos tentar alimentar
com um gafanhoto não sei se ela vai ser
dele é muito perigoso e fazer isso com
uma mão e vou tentar soltar aqui um
caixa que fica só eu voltar a uma trégua
só tenho de cumpri la não consigo nem eu
não consigo ver o pessoal eu sabia deu
errado deu errado acha que eu serão três
gringos lá dentro é tavam que espalhados
no meu quarto 22 minutos a tentar
apanhar os mas consegui jogos coloquei
aqui dentro do carinho pessoal e não se
conseguem ver mas tem um grill é um
evento muito perto da minha aranha nem
se ela está dormindo assim a qualquer
momento é tranquila vai atacar o grill
é porque é uma perdedora muito rápida
mesmo é uma fêmea e normalmente os
filmes são muito mais rápidas portanto é
só chorar é só esperar que ela vai ter
caos que ela fosse uma maletinha escalar
ele mas como um grilo só é bem pouco ela
não vai então é só o aspecto que está
daqui da minha nova ter amplo para lá
espera lá eu ainda não tem nome para ela
seria comentem o máximo de nomes que
vocês acham que fica bem aqui na
tranquila eo possível excluir com vocês
qual é fácil não deverão escolher tudo
junto e não pra tranquilo só sejam
originais
ok sinta melhor muito obrigado também ao
pessoal da portuguesa que não forneceu a
ter ampla e me ajudou a construir o
salário todo e ohio vocês foram brutais
e só se quiserem algum animal para selar
na lojas têm muito e eu também tenho um
canal com o tempo passei no link
acompanhava se um vídeo com amigas pero
também e esse pessoal já sabe quanto com
voz mega lá e pra eu continuar a fazer
aqui coisas poderão colocar em cima
vocês vão ter dois vídeos muito loucos
mesmo que também podem ver vão se
divertir e tenho certeza que aqui
embaixo vocês podem se inscrever aqui no
canal da fran gay só agora vou cuidar
aqui da minha tranquila fiquem vai até a
próxima